[Applause]
i'm freaking out
i'm freaking out i love you so much i'm
freaking out
hi how's it going i would
i i'm so curious was there a light bulb
moment an
aha moment when and where and
how did you know you had the funny gene
did you enjoy
like the smiles on people's faces
what was it because we're now addicted
to you
and i i mean seriously was there a time
and a place
was there was there something that you
hooked into
where you're like i like this feeling or
i like giving it to people
how did you stumble upon your comedic
amazingness
well i mean i firstly i never thought i
would be
an actor i was um a youth ambassador for
australia
living in southern africa and i got
malaria really badly
and had this hallucination that i was an
actress and then i won an academy award
so i was like that just made me go into
acting
and then i thought well i've got to be
like a serious actress like dame judi
dench
and i was in my very first play in
sydney australia and i was being really
serious
and people just started laughing at me
and it made me like really angry and i
was just sort of seeing the lions
really angry because i was like this is
i'm a serious actress and people just
started laughing and i think so ever
since that very first play that i did
i found that i had something that people
liked
laughing at me about um
but really like no one in my family
thought i was funny they all think like
they're funnier than me
uh so yeah so no no one thought oh she's
hilarious
as a kid i just kind of fell into it i
think
did you like binge on comedy was it a
big thing for you
or just not oh i remember
i mean because i love watching tv and
movies um but i think the first woman i
ever saw on screen
writing and performing her own material
was jennifer saunders in that show
absolutely fabulous yeah this show
and i remember just going whoa like a
woman can be just so
outrageous on screen and and really
enjoying that and also i will say
oh i've got to tell you this your movie
never been kissed
oh my god is like the cutest funniest
movie i love that movie so much
you literally turned me into josie
grossie
i mean josie grossi is she's the
enthusiasm that's
unbridled and we're sometimes taught
along the way that you know that might
not be
cool and i think things have changed a
lot like now nerds are hot they used to
be nerds and now nerd is like sexy
so definitely the script gets flipped
but
i you know i i went through a really big
awkward phase of my life
and i went through a really awkward face
i had a snaggle tooth
his teeth here i actually had like a
legit snaggletooth
for like five years as a teenager it was
not pretty i was uh
yeah super super dorky also i was very
into math
um the math olympiad team
stuff like that yeah i was super
academic that's why nobody thought i
would become an actress like
my mom cried when i told her because she
thought i would have been a great lawyer
or a doctor
gosh that's so interesting when i was
homeschooling my kids this year
i was so relieved because you know
they're like at first
grade level and i was like oh i can do
this because i didn't really go to
school i was
raised on movie sets and they send you
for like three hours of tutoring and
you know but so math intimidates me so
much
i i see numbers and they they haunt me
um
but i've always admired the love of math
because in math is the answers to the
universe
well i used to love it and i guess and i
went to an all girls school and it was
cool
to like be really good at math so um i
always like encourage
my young ladies out there to like really
don't be afraid of your skills guys like
really you know big up yourself and like
be proud if you're really smart at
school and if if you're not so smart
just try your best and you know you
could become an actor where it doesn't
matter if you study or not
it's true it's really true i love
hearing that my girls
go to an all-girls school by the way
yeah
shout out to all the girls school it's
great i mean
i know and a lot of people see me like
on instagram or
like just being crazy and having like
this fun actress life
but what they didn't see is like that i
went to university and i've got
two degrees and a law degree and an arts
degree
and and really did study hard as well so
girls
you know keep up with your schoolwork
that message is so important
i love hearing from you that like how
smart you are and to go the distance and
to stick with
it and keep all your options open yeah
because you never know
international movie starter may not
happen for you
so you always got to have backup options
so
i could be a lawyer at any moment if if
something happened and uh
yeah the movies didn't work out i could
just go back and you know
help uh prosecute criminals i was gonna
say what type of law do you do
i actually specialize in space law which
is this new
frontier because at some point uh space
tourism will become a big thing and
like people might colonize the moon and
what do you do if that happens
so i thought that would be a fun
elective to take
and i knew at that point maybe i
wouldn't be a real lawyer so it was a
fun elective
it's so interesting i'm always like
fascinated you know with
the mars thing because i'm like god
we've got some real problems here
are you just ditching earth and want to
colonize
mars what's the deal here why so much
about
mars we have bridges to fix why mars but
i i understand at the same time
a plan b or the interest in
space and i love the moon i love her so
much
yeah well i mean it is just such an
inspiration to talk to you
it's so cool
you